CBS's broadcast the parade for 59 years
you can see the Thanksgiving Day Parade
on CBS right after CBS this morning and
you'll be in good hands
Kevin Frazier and Kelty Knight from
Entertainment Tonight are back hosting
this year's broadcast and I will
actually see them a little bit later
when I appear on their show they join us
from the parade right now guys where are
you exactly
along the route we're at sixth Avenue
and 53rd right across from the Hilton
you can see the Hilton in the background
but I mean we have a beautiful spot we
know you're on your way so we're waiting
on you I mean you're here to hold up the
parade if you don't get here soon
Michelle can handle everything so tell
us what you got two guys well Miranda
Lambert is coming by to perform so that
will be one of the things that's going
to be very exciting plus a couple of of
the Broadway shows yeah the Broadway
cast of Mean Girls will be performing
and we're just so excited 50 million
people are going to be tuning in to
watch this around the world 3.5 million
fans lining the streets we are down
early this morning we had people from
Florida from Detroit everyone's braving
why yeah
very very cool the parade is in its 93rd
year this year and it's just such a
special holiday tradition it really
kicks off the holiday season and I'm
just so excited it's so festive you know
listen here's the deal guys
all these people come out here early in
the morning they get a prime spot they
want to see the balloons fly we hope
they are flying today and that's the big
big thing because you have folks from
all around the world every one of the 50
states we will and by the way for you at
home just sit tight
cut along with the blanket stay in your
pajamas but please please please send us
a message on social media using the
hashtag T day CBS and maybe you'll make
the broadcast yeah I want to see babies
with funny hats on dogs and costumes and
your face thank you very much food I
like the dogs in funny costumes at
someone who's actually been there
watching live and in person I have to
tell you the best seat in the house is
in front of your TV set oh right
guys so you know we're gonna go to here
or right here you know we're gonna ask
you it's Thanksgiving what are you
thankful for sure Oh Kevin what listen
first of all always thankful for my
family and getting to spend this time
with my entire family who's here today
but just being here we love doing this
together felt thankful for Kevin Frazier
is that I know it sounds weird but we
really do work closely tonight looks
like one little family if we could turn
the camera around you would get to see
the same crew here each and every year
spend Thanksgiving with this crew and
it's cool Kevin say hi to Yasmin for me
I will she'll be here soon don't worry
her and the boys are coming you tell
your family hello and Michelle save us
some food I will come on okay shout out
to your turn and our crew Happy
Thanksgiving we will see you guys soon
on the road down here Kevin Frazier in
Kelty night thank you very much again
you can watch the Thanksgiving Day
Parade right here on CBS just after CT
Oh